JONATHAN SHEFFI: Hi, and
welcome to Cloud onAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name's Jonathan Sheffi.
I'm the product manager for
Genomics and Life Sciences
at Google Cloud.
And today we're talking about
powering genomics research
on Google Cloud Platform.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So a few topics we're
going to talk about today.
First I'm going to tell
you a little bit about how
you can accomplish genomic and
clinical data mining together
using BigQuery.
Then I'll tell you a
little bit about how
you can run batch workflows
at scale using Pipelines API.
Then we'll hand it over to my
friend Geraldine from the Broad
Institute to tell you a bit
about GATK4 and the FireCloud
platform.
She'll also tell you about
how their team optimized
GATK4 for Google Cloud.
And then Keith from
Google will tell you
a bit about some of the
really cool innovations
that are happening
right here at GCP.
But first, I want to tell you
a little bit about the team
that I'm a part of.
This is a team that started
at Google just last year.
It's called the Cloud for
Health and Life Sciences team.
We brought together product
managers, software engineers,
solution architects,
and a commercial team
to help organizations
do all sorts
of amazing things with
health and life sciences data
using Google Cloud.
Whether it's an
academic institution,
whether it's a pharma company,
a provider, a payer, a health
products or services
company, we want
to help you use any kind of
health and life science data
type in Google Cloud
more effectively.
In particular, the product
teams that I'm a part of
are focused on a
few key modalities--
clinical data, so
EMR data, EHR data,
other kinds of
phenotypic datasets;
imaging data, that's DICOM,
PACS, PET scans, MRIs, X-rays;
and my team, the Genomics
and Life Sciences team,
where we're dealing with
not only genomic data,
but all kinds of other
biomedical datasets.
So it could be
microbiome, RNA-seq,
and others, flow cytometry.
Why we're doing this is because
our vision is that there's
going to be a convergence of
these data types in the cloud,
where for whatever sample
you're working with,
whether it's yeast or an
entire human population,
it will be helpful for you
to be able to analyze data
across these different
modalities together.
And that's what we're enabling.
So let's talk a bit about what
that can look like, especially
coming from the genomics and
life sciences point of view.
So one of the
products from my team
is called Variant Transforms.
Variant Transforms is
an open source tool
to help you manage your
genomic data using BigQuery.
You can think about it as a way
to take your VCFs from panels,
exomes, or genomes and import
them directly into BigQuery
using the inherent VCF scheme
that you're presenting.
From there, you can do
things like calculate
your allele frequency,
or build a cohort,
or do ad hoc exploration
of that dataset.
But I think we all know that
where these kinds of datasets
get really exciting
is when we join them
with other kinds of data.
So that's exactly why a company
called Color in the Bay Area
did.
And I want to tell you a
little bit more about that.
So Color is a health
services company.
They offer very affordable and
accessible genetic testing.
And they have a 30
gene panel in cancer.
And they also have an existing
database of phenotypic data,
some health history
data, and report data
that was sitting on
Postgres database.
The problem they
had is that they
wanted to be able to expand that
test by mining the raw sequence
data alongside the other data
they had available on those
samples.
The cloud provider they'd
been using up till now
didn't really have a mature
enough managed data warehouse
solution like BigQuery, which
is so great for these kinds
of scalable queries.
So what'd they do?
They used Variant
Transforms-- as I mentioned,
totally open source tool--
for bringing all of that data
into BigQuery.
They took the data from the
Postgres database, which
had a bunch of
biomarker information,
and put that in BigQuery
and joined it together.
On top of that,
their data scientists
stood up all kinds of really
cool machine learning tools
and built a whole
bunch of great models.
So what happened?
Well, they got all the feature
engineering done in one week.
And they created
three novel models
that outperformed an
existing major clinical model
for predicting
certain biomarkers.
In fact, their test, which is
actually designed for cancer,
they found out worked in
a completely unrelated
therapeutic area.
This is really exciting.
It may become a publication,
it may become a novel test.
But we're really excited
about the kinds of results
that our customers are
achieving by joining
their genomic data with other
data types using BigQuery.
So I'm going to switch
gears for a minute
here from tertiary analysis
to secondary analysis.
Your data, if you're
watching this,
you're probably processing
lots of samples,
perhaps in cloud environment,
perhaps somewhere else.
And you're thinking about
how you can really scale up
that work of your pipelines.
So our team also
offers an API called,
not surprisingly, Pipelines API.
Pipelines API helps you run
bioinformatics pipelines
at scale and achieving great
metrics around turnaround time
and cost.
You can stand up all kinds of
great industry standard tools,
like GATK, which you're going
to be hearing more about.
And you can optimize
for parallel execution.
And you can leverage a
lot of great innovations
in Google Cloud, like
preemptible virtual machines,
GPUs, regional storage.
You're going to hear
a little bit more
about that later today.
We've also brought together
a phenomenal ecosystem
of platform partners
and workflow engines
to help deal with all this.
So soon you're
going to hear more
about Broad Institute and
their FireCloud platform,
and you'll also hear about the
Cromwell open source workflow
engine, which are great ways
of running your workflows
and leveraging the
power of Pipelines API.
We also have other partners,
such as WuXi NextCODE,
DNAstack, Seven Bridges, and the
Nextflow open source workflow
engine.
The kinds of results
that people get
from leveraging Pipelines API
is this kind of massive scale.
So for example, the team at
Stanford School of Medicine
is being able to run thousands
of genomes in parallel, what
today they say feels
like infinite resources,
and being able to boot up
a lot of machines at once
to accomplish a batch workflow
in a very short period of time,
while still focusing
on low cost.
Our friends at the Broad have
used Pipelines API quite a bit,
shall we say.
They process over 250
genomes every single day.
They are now working
with over 35 petabytes
of data in Google Cloud.
And just last year,
consumed over 100 million
compute core hours.
And they're scaling up their
work because of the innovation
within Pipelines API.
So let's talk a little
bit about some of the work
that they're doing.
The Broad gnomAD team
recently called Variants
on the gnomAD dataset
with the GRCh38 reference.
And the problem they had was
that gnomAD, as you might know,
it's 79,000 whole genomes
that were previously
called with HD19.
They wanted to be
able to call variants
for that entire data set
using GATK4 and GRCh38.
So they were able to
spin up 79,000 workflows
and call the variants for the
entire dataset in three days.
It's a really
exciting result, and I
think it's a great example
of the kind of scale
you can achieve using
Pipelines API and engines
such as Cromwell and
platforms such as FireCloud.
So what's next for that team?
They're going to
be calling variants
for exome data on
gnomAD as well, again,
using some of the same
technologies and techniques.
So speaking of innovations
with Pipelines API,
just last month, we
released a brand new version
of Pipelines API for our
ecosystem of platform partners
and workflow engines.
What's new?
Well, first you're able
to run multiple Docker
containers per instance.
This is really helpful,
because you can now
run service containers
in the background
while the workflow is
running in progress.
We also make it a lot
easier for tool authors
to be able to inject their own
containers around a workflow.
Localization and delocalization
of files is much, much simpler.
It's just now a
container instruction.
And there's also-- also
my favorite feature--
a lot more information is
available to our platform
partners and workflow
engine partners
on the information about the
transition between states
and on failure modes.
So for example, when I
have a pipeline that fails,
why did it fail?
Did it run out of memory?
Did it simply crash?
Did something happen
to the node somehow?
Did I get preempted?
That information was a
little hard to access before.
And now it's much easier and
provides a better experience
for whatever workflow engine
or platform you're using.
We've also made it easier to
specify regions and zones,
and much easier to specify
minimum CPU platform options.
Keith will tell you
a little bit more
about that soon in terms of how
you can bring up custom VMs.
So all this great talk
about secondary analysis--
let's learn a little bit
more about how people are
doing this in the real world.
So now I'm going to invite up my
friend Geraldine from the Broad
to tell you more about
GATK4 and FireCloud.
GERALDINE A. VAN DER
AUWERA: Thanks, Jonathan.
It's good to be here.
I'm going to talk today
about GATK4 and FireCloud,
and the way we have
been working to make
our pipelines
available, accessible
to the wider community
of researchers.
Now, first I want to
start with a little bit
of a recap of what is GATK
exactly, what that covers.
So GATK is a genomic
analysis toolkit.
And this is roughly the
process for genomic analysis,
specifically with a focus
on variant discovery.
If you think that
you're starting
with biological material,
for example, blood samples,
you want to extract
DNA from that, put that
through the sequencing machine,
that's going to produce
a huge pile of short reads.
Those short reads,
that's the raw data
that we're going to be
using in our pipelines.
The end result that
we want to get to
is a list of variation mutations
in the individual genome
or genomes of a
group of individuals.
And so the pipeline, which
is what GATK constitutes,
is going to take that raw
data, do some cleanup,
do some mapping to find
out where the reads belong
in the genome, and then
do the analysis that
enables us to identify those
variations, those mutations
in individual genomes,
which is ultimately what
the researcher cares about.
Now, these tools have been
around for a long time,
about a decade, which
honestly, in genomics time,
pretty much like a century.
And for a long time, they were
evolving kind of naturally.
We're just improving
our ability to just push
the scientific boundaries
of what we could identify.
Now, over the last few
years, as Jonathan mentioned,
there's been a huge
explosion in the size
of the genomic data
and the datasets
that we need to be
able to analyze.
And so we've put a lot
of work into making sure
that the tools and
the pipelines can
cope with that huge explosion
in the size of datasets.
And specifically,
we built what we
call GATK4, which is version
4 of the GATK toolkit.
I'm not going to go
into a detailed laundry
list of features,
but the main themes
are that we've really improved
the technical performance,
the speed and
scalability of the tools.
And that has involved
a complete rewrite.
We've rewritten that entire
software code base from scratch
to be able to cope
with the demands
of the genomic workloads
that are now today's reality.
But it's not just about
the technical performance,
although that's very important.
But we've also put a lot
of work into expanding
the scope of analysis to be able
to cover more variant types.
So where previously we were
very focused on germ line short
variants-- that was kind
of what we were known for--
now we've expanded that to cover
all the major variant classes,
including copy number,
structural variation
in both germline and
somatic mutations.
So we're now able to cover
almost all of these use cases.
And the remaining one that is
not quite implemented today,
somatic structural
variation, is planned.
We have that on the roadmap.
We hope to deliver
that later this year.
And so the idea is that you
have all these pipelines that
allow you to really do all the
scientific work that you need
related to variant discovery.
Now, the thing is--
and there's been two big
pushes in that direction.
One is just developing
the right methods
to produce those end results,
but also improve the speed
and performance of the tools.
And that has involved leveraging
a lot of the improvements in,
for example, machine learning
that have really flourished
over the past few years.
Now, if we look at these
pipelines, all of them
involve a sizable
number of steps
involving different tools.
And for the individual
researchers,
it's not easy to
implement this at scale.
And so one of the things
we've been focused on lately
is formalizing
pipeline definitions,
which we call the GATK
best practices, which
a researcher can take
and apply to their data
without having to figure
out, by themselves,
how to implement this.
So we call that the GATK
best practices pipelines.
But there's still a big step
between having the pipeline
definitions and being
able to implement that.
And so we've gone
a step further,
and now we're making available
these pipelines as ready
to run pipelines that are
preloaded in a platform
that we call FireCloud,
which runs on Google Cloud.
And so we have these workspaces
that contain the pipeline,
as well as example data.
And so anyone can go and
clone one of those workspaces,
run the pipeline as it is
preconfigured on the example
data.
They can also upload
their own data
and run the pipeline
on their own data.
And that way you have the
GATK best practices pipelines
just available in ready to
run state out of the box.
So hopefully, I've
got you interested.
Now I want to tell
you a little bit more
about FireCloud's
platform itself.
OK, so FireCloud is meant to
be a self-service analysis
portal that anybody can access.
And specifically, anybody
can access for free.
So we built this originally
for Broad researchers,
but we made this
available for free.
Of course, it's using
Google Cloud resources,
so you still have to pay
Google Cloud for storage
and compute cost,
things like that.
But we do have a
free credits program
that you can use to get
started with the platform
to test it out without taking
any financial risk yourself.
Now, the platform itself
offers a number of services,
including the ability
to manage your data,
to share your data securely, and
to run workflows on your data.
So we've got a
number of pipelines
that are preset that you can run
on your data in this platform,
but you can also bring
your own pipelines,
either variations of ours,
or just different workloads
that you need to run.
Because we understand
that many people
use other tools besides GATK.
And we can use this through
the web portal, which
is a graphical user interface.
You can also use
it through the API
if you prefer to
interact programmatically
with the platform.
And as of last week, we
also have, now, the ability
to spin up Jupyter
notebooks on smart clusters,
so you can follow-up your
batch execution, your pipeline
execution with interactive
analysis of the results
that they produce.
Now, let's look
a little bit more
closely at how batch
execution of workloads
works in FireCloud.
Don't worry about the
details yet, but let's
look at the overall system.
Here we have two researchers who
have access to this workspace.
The workspace
encapsulates everything
that's involved in a
particular project,
including the definition
of the data that's involved
and the methods.
And that's also the
place where you're going
to be executing pipelines.
So you also have access to
pipelines, the workflows.
That's the stacked scripts that
you see above the workspace.
And you have a number of data
buckets that are available.
Now, the way it works is
that the data is stored
in the buckets on Google Cloud.
So your data is going to
live in Google Storage,
either associated with the
workspace or in other buckets.
You can also compute on
data that's elsewhere
in the data library, which
are public datasets that
are provided.
The workflows are WIDL scripts.
WIDL is a workflow
definition language.
The GATK pipelines
are all provided
as preloaded WIDL scripts.
And that contains the definition
of your actual workflows.
Now, when you go to run
a workflow on your data,
all you need to do, really,
is connect the workflow
with the inputs.
The inputs, that's
the data that's
defined in your
data model, which
describes what files
you have available
and how they plug
into the workflow.
So you have your workflow.
You have your data definition.
You're going to launch one of
these workflows on your data.
That's going to be handed off
on the backend to Cromwell,
which is the execution engine.
And Cromwell is going to take
care of everything for you.
So it's going to
execute your workflow,
talk to the Pipelines API,
which Jonathan talked about,
and run your workflow on
the Google Compute Engine,
and then write back the outputs
to your workspace data bucket.
So that's how you run a
pipeline in FireCloud.
And specifically, if you
you're using one of the GATK
best practices pipelines
which is preloaded,
you can get started
with this very quickly.
And it abstracts away
all the difficulties
of implementing these kind
of complicated pipelines
on the cloud.
And what's really neat is,
like I said, as of last week,
you can follow up and use
the results that you have.
Now you can explore your
results interactively
in Jupyter notebooks.
So that shows you how to
access and run the GATK4
pipelines in FireCloud.
Let's talk a little bit
about what it costs,
because when we started
migrating our workflows
to the Google platform,
it became clear to us
that there were some great
opportunities to cut down
the cost of operation.
And here I'm going
to talk briefly
about the various
strategies that we
used to bring down dramatically
the cost of operating
our genome analysis pipeline.
Now, the main strategies
that we used--
and we developed
this with quite a lot
of friends, quite a lot of help
from our friends at Google--
have been in several
different categories.
One was this idea of task
splitting and persistent disk.
Now, the idea here
is that when you
have your tasks in
a workflow, you're
allocating for each task.
You're allocating some
resources, some disk
size, some processor size.
Though the beefier the
machine, the bigger the disk,
the more you're going to
pay for this hardware.
And so what you want
to do is make sure
that the allocation is
commensurate with the needs
of your task.
And we have found that
there are various ways
that we can optimize how tasks
are either split up or bundled
together, depending on
what their computational
requirements are, and what
is the size of the inputs
and outputs that we
need to store locally
to really optimize the
allocation resource requests.
Now, the other-- and that
kind of goes with it.
The other big strategy--
and this is personally
my favorite--
that we've applied
to bring down costs
is the use of preemptible VMs.
Preemptible VMs are
machines where you get them
at a really steep discount.
You pay 20% of the normal
price for a machine.
But that comes with
the understanding
that you can get kicked off
the machine at any time.
So for really long running
jobs, that's not so desirable.
But if you're running
really short jobs
or up to a few hours, it's
actually a really good deal,
because you're paying a
lot less for the compute.
And there's some
logic built in so
that if you do get
kicked off the machine,
there will be some
automatic retries.
And you can even tune
how many attempts
you want to do on preemptibles
before defaulting back
to a regular machine
that you have for sure.
And so by doing that, and
by switching virtually
all the steps in our pipelines
to use in preemptible VMs,
we've gained an
additional 35% savings
on the cost of running
our gene pipeline.
And now, the final piece in the
puzzle, the last big strategy
that we've applied to cut down
costs of our pipeline operation
is to be really smart about
how we're accessing the data.
JP Martin at Verily
Life Sciences
contributed some
really valuable code
to HTSJDK, which
is an open source
library that underlies GATK.
It's what GATK uses to read
in and write out files.
And the code that JP contributed
allows us to read data directly
from the bucket
instead of having
to copy the file
to the local disk
before we can compute on it.
And that makes a big difference,
because, for example,
if we're parallelizing
across genomic regions,
if you think that
normally you would
have to copy an entire genome
BAM file to local disk,
but now you can
skip that and just
copy the little piece of
data that you actually
want to run on.
That allows you
to go much faster,
because you don't have to
wait for 100 gig BAM file
to get copied.
And it also allows you to
allocate a much smaller disk
space.
So that ties into the first
strategy that I mentioned,
where we can use much
smaller disks for each task.
And if you're
thinking, well, this
is going to be used across
thousands or tens of thousands
of genomic intervals,
and then replicated
across tens of thousands
of genomes themselves,
that amounts to fairly
significant savings again.
In this case, 15% savings on
the total cost of the pipeline.
And the results of all
of that, in aggregate,
is that from an initial
cost of $45 per genome
to process an entire
genome on Google Cloud,
we've cut that down
to $5 per genome.
And we've done some additional
tweaking that I can share.
We're seeing now that with some
of those additional tweaks,
we can actually bring down the
cost of the pipeline right now
to $3.65 per genome.
So that just gives
us so much more bang
for our research buck.
It has made a huge
difference in terms
of what we can do at
the Broad Institute
with our genomic pipelines.
I want to be clear that we're
still offering best practices
pipelines that are generic
that can run anywhere,
but we have this version
of the GATK4 pipelines
that is very
optimized, very deeply
optimized for Google Cloud.
It's what we run in production.
We make that available so
that everybody can benefit
from this optimizing work.
You can try this
pipeline in FireCloud.
It's preloaded in
the workspace that
lives at the URL that's on your
screen, the $5 genome analysis
pipeline, which we
might have to have
to update the name of to
the $3 genome pipeline.
And hopefully, that will
just keep going down.
So that covers the
work that we've done
so far with GATK and FireCloud.
I'm going to throw it over to my
friend Keith from Google, who's
going to talk about
platform innovation.
KEITH BINDER: Great,
thanks Geraldine.
So innovation is something
that we hold dearly at Google.
And as you heard from
Jonathan and Geraldine,
our innovation stems from
things like the Pipelines API,
to BigQuery, even to stuff
like preemptible VMs.
It's fascinating to
think that for the price
of a cup of coffee in New York,
you can do an entire genome
analysis.
To me, that's amazing.
But our innovation
doesn't just stop there.
At Google, we don't
believe you should simply
lift your workload or
application into the cloud.
We believe that you
should lift, shift,
and improve upon that
workload and application.
And the improvements
take form of some
of the cost innovation
and technical innovation
that we have.
For instance, we have a
live migration capability.
So your instances can
seamlessly migrate
to a machine during
maintenance windows
without any user intervention
and without any planned
downtime.
This is something
we took advantage
of during the recent Specter
meltdown vulnerabilities,
whereby we migrated
our entire customer
environment seamlessly, without
them having to be involved,
in order to address
that vulnerability.
Additionally, we have
custom machine types.
So we know that
applications sometimes
don't fall into a specific
ratio of CPU and memory.
So we allow you to define
what that ratio is.
Maybe you need four
cores and 80 gig of RAM.
We don't stop you
from doing that.
Additionally, we
have recommendations
using our vast history
of machine learning
to look at how an
instance is performing
and say, you know
what, if you change
the core count on this machine,
or maybe reduce the memory
footprint, not only will
your instance still run,
but you'll save a
couple dollars as well.
We believe that you should
pay for what you consume.
And to that end, we
have per second billing.
So if your instance
runs for 73 seconds,
you're going to
pay for 73 seconds.
You're not going to pay for
120 seconds, or even more.
We also have extremely fast
startups for our instances.
We're talking about
a matter of seconds.
So this gets you up and
running as fast as possible.
And lastly, we allow you to
resize your disks on the fly.
If you need a bigger
disk, we allow
you to do that
seamlessly, as well
as increasing the IOPS for that
disk as you make it bigger.
Now, innovation isn't only
about technology and cost.
We think security is also a
strategic part of innovation
at Google Cloud.
And it starts with
you, the customer.
By default, without you
having to do anything,
all of your data in transit
and at rest is encrypted.
You don't have to worry
about any PKI infrastructure.
about any key management.
Now, of course,
if you are a type
that likes to manage your own
keys, we allow you to do that.
But knowing that you
don't have to do that
is an extremely, extremely
important benefit.
And this notion of
security and encryption
extends into our cloud stack.
It starts at the silicon level.
We made our own
in-house secure chip
that we put on every
peripheral device.
And that secure chip will
check to make sure it's
a trusted root during boot.
If it detects any abnormality
during the manufacturing cycle,
or even during steady state,
that machine in our data center
will not boot and will be
reported to our engineers.
That extends into our
server environment.
We have our own custom
servers that we manufacture.
And having the ability
to make our own servers,
we eliminate all
the extraneous stuff
that you may have in a
server from off the shelf.
You don't necessarily
have to put in video cards
if they're not needed.
So not only do we free
up valuable real estate
on that server to introduce
additional CPU and RAM,
but we're actually
eliminating a threat vector
by eliminating potential
vulnerabilities
in those peripheral devices
that you don't even need.
We also extend this to
our storage environment
and our network environment.
They are both
custom and allow us
to own not only the
hardware, but the software
and the firmware stack as well.
And lastly, at a holistic
level, our data centers
have both logical and
physical security.
To that end, because we own
the hardware, the software,
and the firmware, are not
reliant upon any third party
to provide patches in
case of a vulnerability.
As we control it, we
can issue those patches
as soon as possible.
Now, you don't have to
take our word for it.
We do annual audits with
our third party consultants
to test the attestation
of our environment.
And when it comes to genomics
and the life sciences,
that one certification that
you may see on the bottom left
is of utmost importance.
And that's HIPAA.
With Google, our entire
cloud environment
is HIPAA certified,
which means you
don't have to worry about
selecting a certain cloud
or instance to
put that PHI data.
As long as you put
it on Google Cloud,
it's automatically covered
by our HIPAA certification.
And you can see, we have a vast
amount of other certifications
as well, such as PCI,
FedRAMP, et cetera.
And lastly, innovation is
not about keeping all of it
close to the chest.
We are a firm proponent of
the open source community.
To that end, we've incubated
numerous projects within Google
that we've released to the
open source environment.
Two of those projects
in particular,
Kubernetes for
container orchestration
and TensorFlow for
machine learning,
are the number one and
number two highest engagement
in all of GitHub.
And not only do we incubate
products and release
into the open source
community, but our employees,
our Googlers, also are
active contributors.
As of 2017, there
are 1,100 projects
in GitHub contributed
by Googlers.
And those Googlers totaled
over 900 employees.
So stay tuned for a live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: All
right, we're back.
KEITH BINDER: All right, some
questions from the audience.
So I've been told this first
question comes from a Jesus
Gomez in New York,
who asks, do I
have to bid for
preemptible instances?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Yeah,
the answer is no.
This is a big difference
with Google Cloud
in that you don't have to bid
for preemptible instances.
You just select them.
And Pipelines API
provides an option for you
to employ both preemptible
CPUs and preemptible GPUs.
You just use them, you get the
discount, and you go to work.
KEITH BINDER: And that's a
flat 80% off for all instances.
And GPUs is a flat 50%.
So definitely take
advantage of that.
How do I get started
with FireCloud?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Yeah,
FireCloud.org is the URL
that you're looking for.
And you can make an account.
You actually get $250 in
credits just to get started,
so that's quite a few
genomes, as you've
heard about some of the
really cool cost work that's
being done by Broad.
Yeah.
KEITH BINDER: And I
have a GCP instance.
I know FireCloud runs on GCP.
Do I have to create a
new billing account?
How do I get my
procurement team involved?
Can I use my existing
account with FireCloud?
JONATHAN SHEFFI:
You actually can.
And there's instructions on
how to do this both on our blog
and on the FireCloud site.
So you can bring your
own GCP billing account.
You can supply the
billing account ID,
and then the charge
for all that compute
goes to your home institution.
So you're really getting all
the benefits of FireCloud.
You're getting all the
benefits of the optimizations.
And yet, your home institution
is getting charged,
so you don't have to worry about
doing a transaction with Broad.
KEITH BINDER: Excellent.
Does the $5 genome include
alignment, or is this GATK?
Great question.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Great question.
So the answer is yes.
So $5 gets you, yes,
that's FASTQ to VCF.
It's the quality metrics.
So it's alignment
and variant calling.
It's really exciting.
I mean, while we're talking
about secondary analysis,
there is so much innovation
happening in this field,
especially from a
cost perspective.
We see GATK-- it is really funny
to think that it was really
just a couple of years ago
that it was 10 times more
expensive--
9 to 10 times more expensive.
And now we're talking about it.
I think a lot of the
buzz in our industry
is always about
the $1,000 genome
and being able to
generate the data cheaply.
But bringing down
the cost by 10x
is pretty significant too
on the informatics side.
So I think that as
we watch this field,
we're going to see the
cost of secondary analysis
get closer and closer to
zero, which is something
I'm personally excited about,
because I think it unleashes
all kinds of new research
questions and opportunities.
KEITH BINDER: It sounds like
we'll be at $3 very soon.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Exactly.
KEITH BINDER: Which
I guess leads us to,
how would I get
started with GATK4?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Yeah.
KEITH BINDER: Or
GATK as a whole.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Exactly.
So again, if you want to run
on the FireCloud platform,
FireCloud.org.
Also, if you want to
get started using GATK4,
we've also put docs
on our website.
So if you go to
cloud.google.com/genomics/gatk,
you'll see docs there that help
you just get up and running
on a sample right away.
KEITH BINDER: And I believe
the Broad website also has--
JONATHAN SHEFFI: And
the Broad website
has a similar URL as well.
KEITH BINDER: And GATK as well.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: And
their blog, yeah.
So both institutions
have blogged about this.
It's such an exciting
development for the community.
KEITH BINDER: And if all else
fails, you can Google it.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Yes.
We have a search engine
to recommend too.
[LAUGHTER]
KEITH BINDER: How
would I get started
with Variant Transforms?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: So Variant
Transforms, as you heard,
I'm so excited about
the work that's
already being done with it.
You're getting sort of an out
of the box variant database
based on BigQuery, which is
such a powerful technology.
So Variant Transforms,
it's on our GitHub page.
The URL is a little tricky,
so probably Google that.
But not only-- if you go to the
Variant Transforms GitHub site,
you'll see not just the
code, not just documentation,
you'll see our product roadmap.
We've actually open sourced
the product roadmap as well.
You'll see the work
that we're doing
to add annotation support.
You'll see the work
that we're doing to add
a BigQuery to VCF pipeline.
Because sometimes you might
be selecting a cohort based
on all the data
you've merged, and you
want to go back to VCF so you
can use some file-based tools.
So that's on the
roadmap as well.
Would really look forward
to folks commenting on that.
We really do look at that page.
And it does inform our
product development
on Variant Transforms.
KEITH BINDER: So
another great example
of contributing to the open
source [INAUDIBLE] community.
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Exactly.
We realized that it was
so important to make
that open source.
It's also written in Python,
like many other stages
of bioinformatics pipelines.
And by open sourcing it,
we know that folks will
have their own VCF schemas.
They'll want to be
able to tweak it.
And we want to just
make that easier.
And we're excited to
give something back
to the community in this way.
KEITH BINDER: Awesome.
Speaking of BigQuery, I've
used it once or twice.
And I see this thing
about public datasets.
Can you tell me which
ones are available?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Yeah.
Oh, man.
I don't know if I can
recite all of them.
But gosh, there's a bunch.
So some of the ones
you might expect--
1000 Genomes, TCGA,
the MSSNG dataset--
there's an autism
research dataset.
There's some data from
the Simons Foundation.
Yeah, there's a
whole list online.
And we'll make sure to
post the URL afterwards
that you can find them.
But we're always interested
in public datasets
that would be good
for the community
and that can be very helpful.
So we see that as an
opportunity, again,
to aid the research
community by hosting
those datasets for free,
and then enabling folks
to compute on that dataset
using some of the tools
we've been talking
about here today.
KEITH BINDER: And
speaking of tools, I
know your team was at the
HIMSS Conference last week.
Anything that you
want to call out?
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Sure, yeah.
So HIMSS was a great
opportunity for us
to introduce the
health care API.
The health care API is actually
built by our Clinical Data
Informatics team.
Makes it really easy for you
to deal with EMR and EHR data
in the cloud.
We're really
interested in helping
people manage that data, process
it, and work with it at scale.
So we're getting the
signal to wrap up,
so thank you so
much for joining us.
It's been a lot of fun.
And thank you for all
the great questions.